Traduttore: David Mammano
Revisore: Siham Ahmeed
Quante volte, in un giorno,
guardiamo il cielo?
O, in una notte limpida,
camminiamo con il naso all'insù,
per ammirare la Luna,
osservare le stelle,
identificare le costellazioni
e magari qualche pianeta
un po' più luminoso degli altri?
Il cielo ha sempre affascinato l'uomo.
Ci fa pensare a chi siamo,
da dove veniamo,
quale sarà il nostro futuro.
Gli antichi, per millenni,
hanno osservato il cielo a occhio nudo.
Hanno identificato i pianeti,
calcolato le orbite,
calcolato la posizione delle stelle,
usato il cielo per misurare il tempo.
Poi, nel novembre del 1609, a Padova,
c'è stato un signore di nome Galileo,
che ha puntato per la prima volta
un telescopio rudimentale verso la Luna.
E, non avendo una macchina fotografica,
ha disegnato quello che vedeva.
E quei disegni sono uguali
alle foto di oggi.
Galileo, Copernico,
Tycho Brahe, Keplero
hanno raccolto l'eredità
di migliaia di anni
di osservazioni ad occhio nudo
e dato il via a quella che noi oggi
conosciamo come “Astronomia da Terra”.
400 anni dopo, è partita
la Conquista dello Spazio.
Nell'anno mondiale della geofisica,
il 4 ottobre del 1957,
dalla base russa di Baikonur,
è stato lanciato il primo
satellite artificiale della Terra,
lo Sputnik, un oggetto
piuttosto grosso, 83 kg,
che dentro non aveva praticamente niente:
una batteria e un antenna
per dire dov’era.
Il 31 gennaio del 1958,
dalla base di Cape Canaveral,
è partito un oggetto decisamente
più leggero, circa 14 kg, l'Explorer 1,
che però a bordo aveva
dei rivelatori di particelle,
dei detector,
che sono gli occhiali che indossiamo
per osservare la Natura
e capire come funziona.
Sono gli occhiali che ci aiutano
a trovare risposte alle nostre domande.
Io sono un fisico che disegna occhiali
per osservare la Natura.
L’Explorer prenderà dati per 111 giorni
e scoprirà le fasce di Van Allen.
Ma in quei 400 anni
i fisici si sono resi conto
che l'Universo ci raccontava
un sacco di storie in più
rispetto a quello
che si aspettava Galileo.
Perché la luce è solo una piccola parte
della radiazione elettromagnetica.
Onde con lunghezza d'onda
di qualche centinaio di nanometri.
Ma io potrei tranquillamente
parlarvi delle onde radio,
che hanno lunghezze d'onde
di decine e centinaia di metri,
che noi a Terra usiamo per ascoltare
le trasmissioni radiofoniche.
E ci sono galassie
che emettono onde radio.
Oppure microonde
come quelle che noi, a Terra,
usiamo per scaldare i cibi.
Oppure infrarossi,
che sono quelli che a Terra usiamo
per cambiare canale alla TV.
E potrei continuare così
per tutto lo spettro elettromagnetico,
fino ad arrivare alle onde
con la lunghezza d'onda
più piccola in assoluto,
i raggi X e i raggi Gamma,
che sono quelli che usiamo
per guardare dentro il vostro corpo
quando vi facciamo una radiografia
o per curare con la radioterapia
un paziente malato di tumore.
Dovete pensare all'Universo
come a un bellissimo romanzo.
Pensate a un romanzo giallo
in cui ogni capitolo
è scritto in una lingua diversa
e ogni capitolo
è una bellissima storia a sé.
Però se non siete capaci
di leggerli tutti,
non riuscirete mai
a risolvere il mistero
e trovare chi è il colpevole.
Allora il compito dei fisici come me
– che disegnano occhiali
per osservare la natura, detector –
è quello di disegnare occhiali
che ci permettano di leggere
ogni singolo capitolo,
metterli insieme e trovare il colpevole.
Allora ben venga
la luce visibile di Galileo,
ma non semplicemente
con i telescopi messi a terra.
Noi abbiamo messo dei telescopi
sopra l'atmosfera,
perché così ci siamo liberati
delle perturbazioni dell'aria
e abbiamo visto anche
i raggi infrarossi e i raggi ultravioletti
che a terra non arrivano.
Il 24 aprile del 1990,
è stato messo in orbita
il telescopio Hubble,
un oggetto enorme, un gigante.
Nella parte più grande
ha un diametro di 4 metri,
è più lungo di un autobus,
pesa più di 11.000 kg,
ha bisogno di 2.100W per funzionare.
E fa fotografie.
Fotografie come i vostri cellulari.
Un po' più grandi, un po' più precisi,
ma fotografie, fotografie come questa.
Questa è la fotografia
di un ammasso globulare di stelle.
Centinaia di migliaia,
a volte milioni di stelle,
che si sono tutte formate
nello stesso momento.
E se io, tramite questa immagine,
riesco a misurare
la luminosità di queste stelle
e paragonarla a quella del Sole,
sono capace di dire quanti anni hanno.
Gli ammassi globulari di stelle
sono i nostri orologi cosmici
e confermano che il nostro Universo
ha circa 13.7 miliardi di anni.
E se invece ci spostiamo
nella parte dello spettro
con le onde con la lunghezza d'onda
più piccola in assoluto, i raggi Gamma,
la storia che vi racconto
è completamente diversa.
Dagli inizi del 1900,
noi fisici parliamo indifferentemente
di particelle e onde.
Ce l'hanno insegnato Einstein e colleghi.
Particelle e onde sono la stessa cosa.
E il risultato è tutta l'elettronica
che voi utilizzate ogni giorno.
I raggi Gamma sono fotoni,
cioè particelle prive
di carica e di massa,
che quindi, quando vengono
emesse da una sorgente,
sono in grado di fare una marea di strada
senza risentire di niente.
E se noi le vediamo,
identifichiamo le sorgenti.
In questo modo,
possiamo studiare le sorgenti
più energetiche dell'Universo,
quelle rappresentative dei fenomeni
più catastrofici dell'Universo.
Possiamo cercare la voce del Big Bang.
E se vogliamo vedere i raggi Gamma
di altissima energia,
costruiamo a terra degli specchi
di 90 cm di diametro,
che poi mettiamo insieme
a costruire specchi giganti
di centinaia di metri quadri di area
che catturano la luce emessa
dalle particelle
prodotte da questi raggi Gamma
quando arrivano
all'interno dell'atmosfera.
E se invece vogliamo vedere
dei raggi Gamma
con un'energia un po' più bassa,
mettiamo un satellite sopra l'atmosfera.
E questo è quello che ho fatto anch'io.
Io ho partecipato alla costruzione
del satellite A.G.I.L.E,
Astrorivelatore Gamma
a Immagini Leggero,
un satellite dell'Agenzia
Spaziale Italiana
che deve aiutarci a leggere il capitolo
dei raggi Gamma e dei raggi X.
Io mi sono occupata
del cuore del satellite,
un cubo di circa 45 cm di lato,
tutto fatto di rivelatori al silicio,
che sono gli stessi rivelatori
che stanno dentro i vostri cellulari,
dentro le vostre macchine fotografiche,
dentro i vostri personal computer,
dentro tutta l'elettronica che avete.
Che sono i rivelatori che usiamo
per vedere i raggi X
quando vi facciamo una TAC.
È, in pratica, una piccola
macchina fotografica
in cui questi raggi Gamma invisibili
diventano pixel accesi
per cui io posso ricostruire
la direzione da cui arrivano
e identificare la sorgente.
Poi questo cuore,
assieme ad altri rivelatori,
è stato messo nel satellite,
con i suoi pannelli solari
per catturare l'energia del Sole;
i sensori stellari per capire dove siamo;
la coperta termica, perché quando è
di fronte al Sole sente caldo,
ma quando è nell'ombra della Terra
ha parecchio freddo.
E questo oggetto di poco più di 350 kg
è stato inserito nel missile
ed è partito il 23 aprile del 2007
dalla base indiana di Sriharikota.
20 minuti ed è arrivato in orbita.
540 km di altezza, orbita equatoriale,
angolo di 2.5 gradi.
90 minuti dopo, passando sopra
la base a terra di Malindi,
ci ha fatto “Ciao!” per dimostrarci
che era ancora tutto intero.
E da 10 anni – ha compiuto 10 anni
un mese e mezzo fa –
osserva le profondità dell'Universo
e ci fa vedere sorgenti
che appaiono e scompaiono,
ci ha fatto cambiare idea su sorgenti
che pensavamo funzionassero
in tutt'altro modo.
Ci fa leggere il capitolo dei raggi Gamma.
Ma i raggi Gamma non sono
gli unici messaggeri “catastrofici”
e energetici dell'Universo.
Ognuno di noi è attraversato ogni secondo
da svariati miliardi di neutrini,
e non se ne accorge.
I neutrini sono particelle
di piccolissima massa
che non hanno carica,
quindi anche loro,
quando sono emessi dalla sorgente,
fanno una marea di strada
senza che niente possa fermarli.
Il problema è
che sono particelle elusive,
cioè interagiscono poco con la materia.
Nel frattempo che io parlo,
di qua saranno passati
decine di milioni di miliardi di neutrini.
E nel frattempo che io ho finito,
quelli saranno già
oltre l'orbita di Marte.
L'unico modo che abbiamo per vederli
è usare tanta materia
e sperare che interagiscano.
E la materia più facile da trovare,
sulla Terra, è l'acqua.
Per questo motivo,
i fisici giapponesi di Super Kamiokande
hanno riempito un'intera miniera,
la miniera di Kamioka,
1.000 metri sotto terra,
con 50.000 tonnellate di acqua pura.
E poi hanno piastrellato
tutte le pareti della miniera
con questi oggetti
che si chiamano “fotomoltiplicatori”.
Hanno un diametro di 50 cm,
funzionano come i nostri occhi,
vedono la luce.
Perché l'unico modo
per vedere un neutrino
è che, quando interagisce col protone
o col neutrone delle molecole d'acqua,
emette elettroni o i suoi fratelli
un po' più pesanti, i muoni,
che nell'acqua vanno più veloci
della velocità della luce nell'acqua.
Perché la luce è la cosa più veloce
in assoluto nel vuoto
– 300.000 km al secondo –
ma in un mezzo le particelle
possono essere più veloci,
e allora emettono luce.
Si chiama radiazione Cherenkov,
è una radiazione blu.
L'unico modo che abbiamo
per vedere i neutrini
è fotografare la luce che deriva
dalla loro interazione con l'acqua.
E se non volete riempire
di acqua una miniera,
usiamo il ghiaccio,
“Icecube”, al Polo Sud.
Un chilometro cubo di ghiaccio.
Pozzi profondi 2.820 metri,
scavati da trivelle che vanno
a due metri al minuto,
in cui calate velocemente
queste colonne di fotomoltiplicatori,
che sono le nostre macchine fotografiche,
e poi il ghiaccio richiude tutto.
E quello che fanno
queste macchine fotografiche
è fotografare la luce emessa
dalle particelle prodotte dai neutrini
quando attraversano la Terra.
E in questo modo, Icecube ha visto
i tre neutrini più energetici
che si siano mai visti sulla Terra.
Hanno un'energia - gli han dato
persino un nome-
Hanno un'energia
che è centinaia di volte
quella dei protoni
che facciamo scontrare all’LHC al CERN.
Sono briciole di Big Bang.
E nell'emisfero boreale,
invece del ghiaccio, usiamo l'acqua.
KM3NeT, nel Mediterraneo,
Tolone, la Grecia,
80 km a sud-est
di Capo Passero in Sicilia,
a 3.500 metri
di profondità,
colonne di queste macchine
fotografiche, tra virgolette,
che devono anche resistere
alle correnti marine
e non andarsene dove vogliono,
per fotografare la luce
emessa dai neutrini
quando interagiscono con l'acqua del mare.
E farci leggere, così,
il romanzo dell'Universo.
L'esplorazione dell'Universo
è un viaggio bellissimo.
Il 5 settembre del 1977 è partita,
dalla base di Cape Canaveral,
la sonda Voyager 1.
Doveva fotografare da vicino
alcuni pianeti.
Il 14 febbraio del 1990 si trovava
a 6 miliardi di km dalla Terra.
Ci ha fotografati
e ci ha mandato questa foto.
Questa foto è nota come “Pale Blue Dot”,
il pallido puntino blu.
Ho anche cerchiato il puntino
per farvi vedere dove siamo.
Carl Sagan, famoso astronomo
e divulgatore, di questa foto diceva:
- È qui.
È casa.
È noi.
Tutti coloro che amate,
tutti coloro che conoscete,
tutti coloro che siano mai esistiti
hanno vissuto qui,
nell’unica casa che abbiamo.
Questo pallido puntino blu.
Tra 300 anni, la sonda Voyager 1
arriverà nella pàtia delle comete,
la nube di Oort,
ma a quel punto la sorgente di plutonio
che fa funzionare l'antenna
si sarà esaurita,
e non potrà più comunicare con noi.
Sarà i nostri occhi e le nostre orecchie,
ma noi non sapremo
quello che vede e quello che sente.
Ma non per questo ci arrenderemo,
perché esplorando l'Universo
ascoltiamo la voce del nostro passato,
cerchiamo risposte alle nostre domande.
Esplorando l’Universo
disegniamo il nostro futuro
perché cresciamo non solo come scienziati
ma cresciamo, soprattutto, come uomini.
Grazie.
(Applausi)